I have to say we've already started to
articulate a very tangible path for
getting growths into something that's
actual eyes in Africa as the young
African were very keen to be part of
solutions and I started to see other
young Africans from the Diaspora bring
back home the lessons I've learned
abroad the expertise and technical
training would have learnt abroad and
some of the investment networks had
established with friends and previous
employers to set up Africa Sony's
private equity companies and the style
to see indigenous capsule emerge from a
young read on trafficking the same
companies like a windows the see over
whether the coach yet with Africa this
is a prime example a lot of these young
Africans who came back home after
studying abroad in Brittany and said I
can do this and today we have an
indigenous oil company that employs
thousands of Nigerians for seeing some
of the things as companies like SAP oil
and many others the shampoo cause of
this world run by a dynamic breed of
young African that are intent on
changing the face and the complexion of
business and introducing dynamic global
best practice to ensure that indigenous
e homegrown African companies comply to
international standards such a revision
to action absolutely we need a lot more
impetus we need a lot more dynamism but
it's already begun the action part of it
has already begun that vision is being
actualized you just need a lot of a
minute